This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over the summer, a new movement started to gain momentum. The movement to ban plastic drinking straws. It's now legal for food service businesses in Seattle to provide plastic straws and utensils. Santa Cruz is among 28 others around the country that have banned or limited plastic straws or are considering it. California and Hawaii are even exploring statewide policies. Environmentalists say 500 million plastic straws end up in the world's oceans every year,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年夏天，一场新的运动开始积聚势头。这是一场禁止使用塑料吸管的运动。现在，西雅图的餐饮企业提供塑料吸管和餐具已属违法。圣克鲁斯是全国其他28个已经禁止或限制塑料吸管，或者正在考虑此举的城市之一。加利福尼亚州和夏威夷州甚至正在探索全州范围内的政策。环保人士称，每年有5亿根塑料吸管最终流入世界海洋，
harming wildlife. The argument against straws is pretty simple. We consume tons of plastic. Not much of it gets recycled. Most of it ends up in landfills and oceans. So why not try to reduce a little of that waste? But like most issues these days, there's been a lot of disagreement about it.
危害野生动物。反对吸管的理由很简单。我们消耗了大量的塑料。其中大部分并没有被回收。大部分最终进入了垃圾填埋场和海洋。那么，为什么不试着减少一点这种浪费呢？但像如今大多数问题一样，关于这一点存在很多分歧。
There's been backlash from a few directions, including conservatives. The left's war against weight for it straws. It's all about your moral preening, right? It's this idea that we are holier than thou. But people with disabilities also spoke up because some of those folks actually need straws in order to drink.
来自几个方面的强烈反对，包括保守派。左派对吸管的战争。这完全是关于你的道德装腔作势，对吧？这是一种我们比别人更高尚的想法。但残疾人也发声了，因为他们中的一些人确实需要吸管才能喝水。
That it might take away their tool of independence. And there's even disagreement about the actual number of straws that we throw away each day. You hear the number 500 million floating around a lot. Apparently, that number came not from a rigorous study, but from a precocious nine-year-old science project. Not a nine-year-old science project, a nine-year-old science project.
这可能会夺走他们独立的工具。甚至对于我们每天扔掉的吸管的实际数量也存在分歧。你经常听到5亿这个数字。显然，这个数字并非来自严谨的研究，而是来自一个早熟的九岁孩子的科学项目。不是九岁孩子的科学项目，是一个九岁孩子的科学项目。
This was really taking on. Even the environmentalists could not agree on whether the straw band was a good thing or not. Yeah, everybody got to have their thing. The real problem is cars, the real problem is buildings, the real problem is, have you seen China's emissions, you know, the real problem is too much nitrogen and, you know, ocean acidification and, you know, just any environmental problem is probably more important than plastic straws. This is journalist Alexis Madrigal. He wrote a great essay about plastic straws
这真的流行起来了。即使是环保人士也无法就吸管禁令是否是一件好事达成一致。是的，每个人都有自己的关注点。真正的问题是汽车，真正的问题是建筑，真正的问题是，你看到中国的排放了吗，你知道，真正的问题是过多的氮，你知道，海洋酸化，你知道，任何环境问题可能都比塑料吸管更重要。这是记者亚历克西斯·马德里加尔。他写了一篇关于塑料吸管的精彩文章
for the Atlantic and he's going to be our guide through all of this because he says that when you zoom out from the Controversies of today and look at the actual history of plastic straws, they can tell us a lot about America. So tell me about some of those bigger themes that emerged when you looked at the history of plastic straws. Yeah, so you know, I used to do this quite a bit like just take some little object and just trace its history. You know, you can look up the patents on Google and you can search around for the companies that made it and you can see its technical evolution. You can just look at it the way you would look at the development of any technology. But the thing that was so crazy about the straw was that it just hits so many of these
为《大西洋月刊》撰写，他将成为我们了解这一切的向导，因为他说，当你从今天的争议中抽离出来，审视塑料吸管的实际历史时，它们可以告诉我们很多关于美国的事情。那么，当你审视塑料吸管的历史时，出现了一些什么更大的主题？是的，你知道，我过去经常这样做，就是拿一个小物体，然后追溯它的历史。你知道，你可以在谷歌上查找专利，你可以搜索制造它的公司，你可以看到它的技术演变。你可以像看待任何技术的发展一样看待它。但关于吸管最疯狂的事情是，它触及了这么多
like real true major trends in the way that the country worked. You know, the straw is there for the invention of American industrialism, for urbanization, for public health reform, for like the suburbanization of the country, fast food, and now of course the culture war. It's there for all of that. And so tell me where it all began. Did someone invent the straw? Or was it just always there?
像国家运作方式中真正重大的趋势。你知道，吸管见证了美国工业主义的发明、城市化、公共卫生改革、国家的郊区化、快餐，当然现在还有文化战争。它见证了这一切。那么告诉我这一切是从哪里开始的。有人发明了吸管吗？还是它一直都在那里？
So there's even scientific studies that show that orangutans go like, hey, this straw-like thing is cool for doing straw-like stuff. So it's probably been around forever. There's ancient versions, etc. But in 19th century America, basically the straw was rye, literally, you know, grass that grows and it's kind of got this hollow tube. And, you know, you dry it, you cut it into shape and that's what would happen.
所以甚至有科学研究表明，红毛猩猩会想，嘿，这种像吸管的东西对于做像吸管一样的事情很酷。所以它可能一直存在。有古代版本等等。但在19世纪的美国，基本上吸管是黑麦，字面意思，你知道，生长的草，它有一种中空的管子。而且，你知道，你把它晒干，把它切成形状，这就是会发生的事情。
That was the straw, straw was straw. Around this time, there were also straws made out of more durable materials, like metal and glass. But then, then, you know, along comes this guy in 1888, named Marvin Stone, and he creates what was then called the artificial straw. And the artificial straw is basically paper dipped in some kind of waxy substance like paraffin, and that becomes this new standard.
那就是吸管，吸管就是草。大约在这个时候，也有用更耐用的材料制成的吸管，比如金属和玻璃。但后来，你知道，1888年，这个叫马文·斯通的人出现了，他创造了当时所谓的“人造吸管”。人造吸管基本上是浸在某种蜡状物质（如石蜡）中的纸，这成为了新的标准。
And it wasn't just that it was artificial. It's also that it was disposable, this straw. That's right. This was basically this incredibly cheap and this incredibly basically disposable and hygienic thing. This wasn't something that came from nature. It was, in fact, produced to a standard, you know. This was a patent straw. And the fact that this straw was hygienic and produced to a standard was important, because straws were becoming a tool in the emerging public health movement that was happening in cities around this time. So you know, the reason public health is emerging at this time is because people in American
而且它不仅是人造的。它也是一次性的，这种吸管。没错。这基本上是一种极其便宜、极其基本上是一次性和卫生的东西。这不是来自自然的东西。事实上，它是按标准生产的，你知道。这是一根专利吸管。而且这根吸管卫生且按标准生产的事实很重要，因为吸管正在成为当时城市中新兴的公共卫生运动的工具。所以你知道，公共卫生在此时兴起的原因是，美国城市里的人们
cities are just like dying all the time of communicable diseases. And a lot of illnesses were spread through dirty drinking water. To understand why this was such a big health issue and why straws would eventually help to solve it, you have to understand how public water fountains worked at the time. In a lot of places in the city, both workplaces and in public locations, the water fountain wasn't like what we think of now, like this little thing with water bubbling out of it or like you press a little button, water comes out. It was just kind of like water that was sitting there or a little tap and you would actually fill a, water comes out, it was just kind of like water that was sitting there
总是死于传染病。许多疾病是通过脏饮用水传播的。要理解为什么这是一个如此大的健康问题，以及为什么吸管最终会帮助解决它，你必须了解当时的公共饮水机是如何工作的。在城市的许多地方，包括工作场所和公共场所，饮水机不像我们现在想的那样，像那种有水冒出来的小东西，或者像你按一个小按钮，水就出来了。它只是有点像放在那里的水，或者一个小水龙头，你实际上会装满一个附在上面的杯子，然后直接喝，它会像，你知道，挂在某种链子上之类的。所以，你知道，一群不同的人都会从同一个杯子里喝水。我们实际上做过一期关于这个的节目。这些早期的饮水机使用一种叫做“公共杯”的东西。它成为了主要目标之一
or a little tap and you would actually fill a cup that was attached to it and just drink out of it and it'd be like, you know, on some kind of chain or whatever. So, you know, a bunch of different people would all drink from the same cup. We actually did an episode about this. These early water fountains use something called the Common Cup. And it became one of the main targets
公共卫生运动者。实际上有一个堪萨斯州的医生开始推动这场反对公共杯的运动。这场运动的基调，很强烈。他们甚至会展示死神从公共杯里喝水，旁边还有一个小女孩。
of the public health campaigners. There was actually like one Kansas doctor who started to like push this campaign against the Common Cup. And the tone of this campaign, its intense. They literally would show the grim reaper taking a drink from the Common Cup with like a little girl next to him.
你只会觉得，天哪，伙计，他们只是从同一个杯子里喝水，你知道吗？在需要公共卫生改革或某种改革的时候，你只需要直击要害。你知道，就像，这会杀死你的孩子，你知道吗？这就是他们采取的方式。许多城市开始要求在某些公共场所设置吸管分配器。在公共杯的情况下，吸管是一种避免把嘴放在别人嘴放过的地方的方法。但不仅仅是公共卫生改革者
And you just be like, Jesus man, they're just drinking from the same cup, you know? And in times when you want public health reform or some kind of reform, you just need to go for the throat. You know, like, this is going to kill your children, you know? That's like, that's where they went with it. A lot of cities began requiring straw dispensers in certain public spaces. In the case of the common cup, straws were a way to avoid actually putting your mouth where somebody else's mouth had been. But it wasn't just public health reformers
促成了吸管的兴起。有两件事。一方面是某种公共卫生狂热。另一方面，是一种叫做苏打水的起泡碳酸饮料的发展。苏打水喷泉在19世纪末、20世纪初的城市中占据了一个非常重要的位置，作为一个空间。
that contributed to the rise of straws. There's two things. There's a sort of public health mania on the one side. And on the other side, there's the development of a certain bubbly carbonated beverage called soda. And the soda fountain occupies this really important place in the kind of late 19th century, early 20th century city, just as a space.
首先，大多数你可以去喝一杯的公共场所都是酒吧，而酒吧主要是男性化的。但城市女性，随着在城市中自由度的增加，想要一个去处。许多城市女性也参与了各种禁酒运动，再说一次，酒吧，那里供应酒，而苏打水喷泉成为了一种干净、健康的替代品。所以有所有这些各种各样的趋势。城市化、兴起、苏打水喷泉、禁酒运动、公共卫生的兴起，
For one, most of the public places where you could go have a drink were saloons, and saloons were primarily gendered male. But urban women, with increasing freedoms in the city, wanted a place to go. And many urban women were also involved in various temperance movements, and again, saloons, they're servant booze there, and soda fountains become this kind of like clean, healthy alternative. So there are all these various trends. Urbanization, the rise, the soda fountain, the temperance movement, the rise of public health,
它们确实都促成了这个蓬勃发展的吸管产业。是的，这很神奇，因为如果你看，有一个《巴特尔克里克调查》，你知道，1924年5月的一份小报纸，他们实际上列出了这发展到了什么程度？你知道这个繁荣有多大吗？他们说，由于美国人对卫生的狂热，人造吸管的产量从1901年的1.65亿增加到每年40亿。一位制造商昨天指出，如果把这些吸管首尾相连，可以在赤道周围绕地球16圈，建造一条蚂蚁地铁。
they all help lead to this booming straw industry, really. Yeah, and it's amazing because if you look at, there's a, the battle, creek inquiry, you know, small paper in May of 1924, they actually sort of list out how far did this go? You know how big was this boom? And they say, due to the Yankee Mania for sanitation, the output of artificial straws has increased from 165 million in 1901 to 4 billion a year. A manufacturer pointed out yesterday that laid end to end these straws would build an ants subway 16 times around the world at the equator.
所以40亿根吸管在背景中，你谈论的是美国当时有1.14亿人口。是的，所以人均35根吸管。那可是很多吸管。我的意思是，我可以肯定地说我实际上可能确实用了。我几乎可以肯定我可能是一个一年用一百根吸管的人。到了20世纪50年代和60年代，吸管将不再是重要文化变革的实际驱动力，而更多地成为一种微小的、微不足道的物体，在更大的趋势中随波逐流，趋势
And so four billion straws in context, you're talking about America has 114 million people at that point. Yeah, so 35 straws per capita. That's a lot of straws. I mean, I can say I actually probably do. I'm actually almost sure that I'm probably like a hundred straw year kind of guy. By the 1950s and 60s, the straw would become less an actual driver of important cultural change and more of this tiny kind of insignificant object surfing along much bigger trends, trends
比如快餐文化的兴起。向世界介绍，纽约，纽约，纽约，还有吃着他的汉堡的蒂姆·伯格，罗纳德·麦当劳。在一位名叫雷·克洛克的商人接管加利福尼亚南部一家名为麦当劳的小餐馆之前，他是一名纸杯推销员。这意味着他也是一名吸管推销员。所以他为莉莉图卢普纸业公司工作
like the rise of fast food culture. Introducing the world, New York, New York, New York, and Tim Burger eating his flound, Ronald McDonald. Before a businessman named Ray Croc took over a little restaurant in Southern California called McDonald's, he was a paper cup salesman. Which meant that he was also a straw salesman. So he worked for the LilyToolup Paper Company
很长一段时间，比如，你知道，15年，在中西部到处跑，向苏打水喷泉推销吸管和杯子。但听到这些真是太神奇了，你知道，他写了一本回忆录，我的意思是，他经营一家汉堡店，他把他的回忆录命名为《磨砺》，我认为这在某种程度上告诉你关于他的一点点信息。
for a long time, like, you know, 15 years, going around the Midwest, selling straws and cups, the soda fountains. But what's amazing to hear, you know, and he wrote a memoir, which, I mean, he ran a burger shop and he called his memoir, Grinding It Out, which I think kind of tells you a little bit about him.
事实证明，当他是一名推销员时，他还在晚上兼职做钢琴家，就像那种，真的感觉不像是一个21世纪的故事。就像它感觉像一个，哇，那是一个奇怪的故事。但雷·克洛克在这本回忆录《磨砺》中，他描述了纸杯在这个一次性的、你知道，卫生的世界里。他说，它们是创新和乐观的。他说，我从一开始就感觉到纸杯是美国前进方向的一部分。
He also turns out he, like, moon-lighted as a pianist when he was a salesman, like just kind of one of those, like, really doesn't feel like a 21st century story. Like it feels like a, like a, wow, that's a weird story. But Ray Crock in this memoir, grinding it out, he describes paper cups in this kind of disposable, you know, hygienic world. He was like, they were innovative and upbeat. He said, I sensed from the outset that paper cups were part of the way America was headed.
他是对的。就像那是美国前进方向的一部分。就像每一个，我们要扔掉一切。我们扔掉手机。你知道我的意思吗？就像我们扔掉电脑。我们扔掉沙发，你知道我的意思吗？就像我们扔掉电脑，我们扔掉沙发。你知道吗？
He was right. Like that was part of the way America was going. Like every, we were gonna throw away everything. We throw away f**k phones. You know what I mean? Like we throw away computers. We throw away couches, you know know what I mean? Like we throw away computers, we throw away couches. You know?
所以克洛克成为了一个核心人物，至少在我的故事里，因为他把这个纸杯产业与美国这种更大的“一次性”概念联系起来。销售所有这些杯子让雷·克洛克接触到了苏打水喷泉，他最终开始从事销售奶昔搅拌机的生意。这把他带到了加利福尼亚南部，解决了第一家麦当劳的运营问题。他在60年代买下了这家小公司，并赶走了原来的所有者。
So Croc becomes a central figure, at least in my story, because he sort of connects this paper cup industry to this greater concept of like disposability in America. Selling all those cups brought Ray Croc into contact with Soda Founts and he eventually went into business selling milkshake mixers This led him to Southern California Resolved the first McDonald's in operation He bought his way into the small company and ousted the original owners in the 60s
这太疯狂了，麦当劳从基本上大约一百家特许经营店发展到一千家。然后就像一直持续下去，纯粹像那种曲棍球棒式的增长。美国公众基本上是吃牛肉的人。而且它每天、每天、每天、每天都很好。人们只是想要更多。我不能给他们所有他们喜欢的东西，但这一件事我肯定能给他们。
This is crazy McDonald's goes from basically like a hundred franchises to a thousand And then just like keeps on going, pure like kind of hockey stick growth. The American public are basically beef eating people. And it wears well, day after day after day after day. People just want more of it. And I can't give them everything they like, but this one thing I sure can give them.
而且你基本上有了快餐和郊区的兴起，食物的包装数量大幅增加。你把食物装在盒子里，这在传统上并不是做事的方式。所以塑料工业在同一时间因为这种一次性趋势而成长。你能谈谈从纸吸管到塑料吸管的转变吗？是的。关于塑料有一点很有趣，你知道，1950年，世界只生产了大约150万吨塑料，这当然很多，因为塑料
And you have with basically the rise of fast food and suburbia, this massive increase in the amount of just kind of wrapping basically for food. You're getting your food in a box and that just hadn't been the way that things were traditionally done. So like the plastic industry at the same time is growing up because of this disposable trend. Can you talk about this transition from paper straws to plastic straws? Yes. One thing that's interesting about plastics, you know, 1950, the world is only producing like one and a half million tons of plastic, which of course is a lot because plastic doesn't
重量很轻，但它并不，它离我们达到的程度还差得远。我的意思是，到了60年代末，产量增长了10倍。所以这确实是在50年代到60年代，基本上人们在问，有没有一个物体？也许它应该是塑料的。你知道吗？所以，你知道，椅子变成了塑料的，
weigh very much, but it's not, it's nowhere close to sort of where we get. I mean, by the late 60s, that production has grown 10 fold. So it's really kind of in the 50s, into the 60s, where basically people are going, is there an object? Maybe it should be plastic. You know? And so, you know, chairs become plastic,
盘子变成了塑料的，一切都，如果你能做到，你就能用塑料做到。所以当然，吸管也成为了其中的一部分。但到了20世纪70年代和80年代，塑料吸管已经无处不在。它们到处都是。虽然吸管设计继续略有演变，但更剧烈的变化发生在吸管行业。
and plates become plastic, and just everything kind of, if you can do it, you can do it in plastic. And so of course, straws become part of this. But the 1970s and 80s, plastic straws had become ubiquitous. They were everywhere. And while straw design continued to evolve slightly, the more dramatic changes were happening in the straw industry.
在这一点上，无论是在我们的经济中，还是在吸管的历史中，组织工厂的机制确实成为了最有趣的物体。这些机制基本上是金融资本主义，开始真正从作为家族企业、组织生产（你知道，在这些地方层面或区域层面）转向，它确实变成了每一件事都只是通过金融化等待赚取的金钱。
At this point, both in our economy and also in the sort of like the straws history, it's really the mechanisms that organize the factories that become the most interesting sort of object. And those mechanisms are basically financial capitalism beginning to really move away from being about family businesses, organizing production, you know, at these kind of local levels or regional levels, and it really becomes everything is just a money waiting to be made through financialization.
通过金融化，亚历克西斯谈论的是过去几十年里经济中发生的一个大趋势。我们的制造业部门一直在萎缩，而我们的金融部门一直在扩张，这对谁最终在吸管和数百万其他消费品上赚钱有重大影响。流向提供资金的人而不是提供
By financialization, Lexus is talking about a big trend in economics that's been happening over the last few decades. Our manufacturing sector has been shrinking while our financial sector has been expanding, which has big implications for who ends up making money on straws and a million other consumer goods. The slice of money that's going to the people who provide the money as opposed to provide
产品的人的那部分钱正在增长。这对事情是如何制造的、谁制造的、工厂位于哪里、有多少人受雇以及工作文化等等都有非常重要的后果。那么马里兰杯发生了什么？这是全国最大的吸管制造商之一。当时他们发生了什么？所以马里兰杯只是一个经典的美国故事，对吧？
the products is growing. And that has really important consequences for how things get made and who makes them and where the factories are located and how many people are employed and the culture of work and all these things. So tell me what happened to Maryland Cup. This is one of the country's biggest straw makers. What would happen to them around this time? So Maryland Cup is just a classic American story, right?
它由这些兄弟拥有，夏皮罗兄弟。他们最初是一家面包店，然后变成了这种面包店服务提供商，然后他们开始制造吸管。所以在他们制造吸管之后，他们制造杯子，在他们制造杯子之后，他们成为了麦当劳的大合作伙伴之一。它基本上保持家族所有。但最终，你知道，最初的管理层走了，人们老了，他们决定卖掉公司。他们把公司卖给了另一家名为福特霍华德的公司。
It's owned by these brothers, the Shapiro brothers. They started out as like a bakery, and then they turned into this kind of bakery services provider, and then they start making straws. So after they make straws, they make cups after they make cups, they get sort of become one of the big partners for McDonald's. And it remained basically family owned. But eventually, you know, the original management is gone, the people are aging, and they decide that they're going to sell the company. They sell the company to another company called Fort Howard.
他们有一位那种强硬的首席执行官，在《巴尔的摩太阳报》上有一个很棒的故事，他们描述了去参加销售会议，马里兰杯的高管们都出现了，新老板们也在那里。他字面上显然有一个翻页挂图，在翻页挂图的一页上，写着，这是你们的旧价值观，它们是服务、质量、响应客户，他们显然字面上就像，
And they had one of these kind of hard charging CEOs, and there's a great story in the Baltimore Sun where they describe going to the sales meeting, the Maryland Cup executives like all show up, and the new bosses are there. And he literally apparently had a flip chart, and on the one page of the flip chart, it said, here are your old values, and they were service, quality, responding to customers, and they're apparently literally like,
翻到翻页挂图的下一页，上面写着，新价值观，利润，利润，利润。哈哈哈哈哈哈。我当时想，该死，那真是个很棒的PPT，你知道吗？马里兰杯曾经是一家非常赚钱的公司，有着高度家族导向的文化。你知道，老板们会打扮成圣诞老人，你知道，感恩节给每个人火鸡，
flip the flip chart to the next page, and it said, new values, profits, profits, profits. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha. I was like, damn, that's quite a PowerPoint, you know? Marilyn Cup had been a very profitable company with a highly family oriented kind of culture. You know, the bosses would dress up as Santa Claus, you know, turkeys to all everybody that Thanksgiving,
你知道，那种家长式的，我们都是一个大家庭的公司。一旦他们进入福特霍华德，它就变成了一个真正的，只是那种，我们将不得不赚钱。所以所有这些人被解雇，他们削减养老金，他们做所有这些基本上就像《阿呆与阿瓜》情节的事情，某种程度上，
you know, that kind of like paternalistic, we are all one big family company thing. Once they go into Fort Howard, it becomes a true, just kind of like, we're gonna have to make money. So all these people get laid off, they cut pensions, they do all this stuff that's basically like the plot of Tommy Boy, kind of,
你还记得克里斯·法利关于俄亥俄州桑达斯基的那部电影吗？女士们先生们，我们真的有麻烦了。所以，Lensky Industries有一个收购我们的提议。但正如你们所知，卡拉汉自汤米的曾祖父铺设第一块砖以来一直是家族所有。如果在我看管下发生改变，我会被诅咒的。弗兰基，如果我们卖掉我们仍然拥有的价值观，
you remember this movie with Chris Farley about San Dusky Ohio? Ladies and gentlemen, we're in real trouble. So, Lensky Industries has an offer on the table to buy us out. But as you realize, Callahan has been family-owned since Tommy's great-grandfather laid the first brick. And I'll be damned if that's gonna change on my watch. Frankie, if we sell Waller values still,
我，每个人都不会停止。你知道，但这在我看管下上演了很多次，弗兰克，如果我们卖掉我们仍然拥有的价值观，我，每个人，都不会停止。你知道，但这上演了很多，很多，很多，很多次。最后，最终发生的事情是，福特霍华德本身被一家私募股权公司收购，然后他们去把一堆不同的纸杯和一次性用品公司合并成一个更大的实体
I, everyone won't stop. You know, but it's played out many my watch, Frank, if we sell well our values still, I, everyone, won't stop. You know, but it's played out many, many, many, many times. And in the end, what ends up happening is that Fort Howard itself then is bought by a private equity firm who then goes and combines a bunch of the different paper cup and disposable goods companies into one kind of larger entity
然后把它拆分出来，背负着一堆债务。这是私募股权中发生的一种经典举措，因为你可以利用这些公司进行借贷，支付给你的投资者，然后拆分出另一家公司，就像漂浮在海洋中，脚上绑着石头一样，对吧？所以从运营上讲，从制造杯子和吸管
and then spins it out loaded with a bunch of debt. And this is kind of a classic move that happens in private equity because you can borrow against these companies, pay your investors, and then spin out this other company that is like sort of floating in the ocean like with the rock's tied around its feet, right? So operationally, like from making cups and straws
以及所有这些东西来看，他们仍然在赚钱，但因为他们必须支付所有这些债务，他们深陷赤字，所以他们必须解雇员工，然后他们必须关闭工厂，这只是那种“秃鹫资本主义”的经典故事。而且事实是吸管，
and all this stuff, they're still making money, but because they have to pay all this debt, they're deeply in the red, so then they have to lay off people, then they have to close factories, and it is just the classic story of kind of like, vulture capitalism. And the fact that the straw,
它们就像，那根吸管，它们就像愚蠢的吸管，这个空容器，不知何故也与美国的金融化纠缠在一起。这对我来说只说明了一件事，那就是每一件该死的事情都与这种生产体系纠缠在一起。[♪ 背景音乐播放，
they're like that the straw, they're like the stupid straw, this empty vessel, somehow also is tied up in the financialization of America. Just says one thing to me, which is that every single goddamn thing is tied up with this kind of system of production. [♪ Music playing in background,
禁止吸管真的能缓解我们的生态问题吗？不。不，我的意思是，它根本达不到问题的规模。我认为我从所有这些事情中看到的贯穿线，因为显然很难将，你知道，1888年的专利到，你知道，第一根人造吸管到，你知道，金融资本主义及其当前形式联系起来。这是我看到的贯穿线。这个国家几十年来一直在流失制造业工作岗位，吸管有贡献。它们在远超其本身的灾难中占了很小的一份。我的意思是，经济继续以这种方式运作，为最富有的人集中财富。你知道，甚至通过吸管进入人们胃里的苏打水也在导致这种肥胖流行病，这威胁到实际上要扭转公共卫生
Can banning straws really make a dent in our ecological problems? No. No, I mean, it's just not up to the scale of the problem. I think the through line I see with all this stuff, because obviously it's hard to connect, you know, a 1888 patent to the, you know, first artificial straw to, you know, financial capitalism and its current form. Here's the through line as I see it. The country has shed manufacturing jobs for decades, straws contribute. They're a little tiny share to environmental disasters that are far beyond it. I mean, the economy continues to work in this way that concentrates wealth, you know, for the very richest people. You know, the sodas that are even like passing through the straws into people's stomachs are contributing to this obesity epidemic that threatens to actually roll back the public health
改革，这些改革在以前的时代确实使人们的预期寿命增长。而且有这样一个巨大的系统。现在它附着在吸管上，这确实有助于创造一次性产品，然后是一次性公司。我发现那种一次性的人，既是这个系统内的工人，也是那些不得不生活在
reforms that actually got people's life expectancies to grow in previous eras. And there's this's this vast system. Now that's attached to the straw that helped really to create disposable products and then disposable companies. I find that kind of disposable people, both the workers who work within this system but also people who just have to live
所有这些由远超他们控制的结构所创造的危机中的人们。所以这几乎就像，虽然我们都能看到周围发生的事情，但只有当你聚焦于最微小的东西时，你才能看到那个巨大的结构，对吧？以这种非常纯粹的方式。可以说这是20世纪最重要的技术成就，至少根据发明者的后代之一。这就是弯曲吸管的故事。稍后回来。
with all of these crises that have been created by structures far beyond their control. And so it was almost like, though we can all see that going on around us, it's kind of only when you focus down on like the most tiny thing that you can see that massive structure, right? In this kind of very pure way. Arguably the most significant technological achievement of the 20th century, at least according to one of the descendants of the inventor. It's the story of the bendy straw. After this.
正如亚历克西斯之前提到的，马里兰杯公司被收购，然后它的买家被收购，以此类推，沿着资本主义快餐链向上。但在马里兰杯出售他们的家族企业之前，他们部分是通过从另一家公司获得一项革命性的关键专利而成长起来的。库尔特·科尔斯特德在这里谈论他们收购的另一家家族企业，柔性吸管公司。所以首先是一些背景。正如亚历克西斯指出的，我们永远不会真正知道人类何时开始使用吸管，但有一个苏美尔人的坟墓
As Alexis mentioned earlier, the Maryland Cup Corporation got bought out and then its buyers got bought out and so on up the capitalist fast food chain. But before Maryland cupped sold their family business, they grew in part by acquiring a revolutionary key patent from another company. Kurt Colesit is here to talk about that other family on business that they bought out the flexible straw corporation. So first a bit of context. As Alexis pointed out, we'll never really know when humans first started using straws, but there's this Sumerian tomb
可以追溯到大约5000年前。在它的印章上，有这些看起来正在用吸管喝水的人物。果然，当人们打开坟墓时，他们在里面发现了这种华丽的饮水管。它由黄金制成，装饰着这些珍贵的宝石。它真的很精致，而且真的很古老。而且它可能不是有史以来最古老的吸管，
that dates back about 5,000 years. And on its seal, there are these figures who appear to be drinking from straws. Sure enough, when people opened up the tomb, they found this ornate drinking tube inside. It's made of gold and decked out with these precious stones. It's really fancy and it's really old. And it's probably not the oldest straw that ever existed,
只是我们发现的最古老的一根。没错，它甚至可能都不接近。没错。但撇开它昂贵的材料不谈，它仍然只是一根直管，当然更耐用，更珍贵。但除此之外，与现代草、纸或塑料吸管没有什么不同。
just the oldest one we've found. Right, it may not even be close. Right. But setting its expensive materials aside, it's still just a straight tube, a bit more durable, a bit more precious, sure. But otherwise, not that different from a modern grass or paper or plastic straw.
所以在很多方面，吸管设计几千年来并没有根本改变，或者至少在20世纪30年代之前没有改变。那就是柔性吸管出现的时候？是的。故事是这样的，发明家约瑟夫·B·弗里德曼
So in a lot of ways, straw design hasn't fundamentally changed for thousands of years, or at least it didn't until the 1930s. And that's when the flexible straw came into existence? Yes. And as the story goes, the inventor, Joseph B. Friedman,
带他的女儿去他兄弟拥有的甜品店喝奶昔。但当他看着他的女儿在用这种普通的直吸管挣扎时，他心想，嘿，你知道，也许有一种更好的方法来做这件事。这就像经典的，你看到一个问题，你解决一个问题，
took his daughter to get a milkshake in San Francisco at a sweet shop owned by his brother. But as he's watching his daughter struggle with this normal straight straw, he thinks to himself, hey, you know, maybe there's a better way to do this. And it's like the classic, you see a problem, you fix a problem,
但这家伙不是靠制造吸管为生的，他是如何创造这个新物体的？所以他从一根简单的现有纸吸管开始。然后他在颈部插入一个中间螺丝，然后他把牙线缠绕在螺丝上，这样当他拧紧它时，它就会产生脊。对，这些脊允许东西弯曲，你知道，像手风琴一样。所以你只是利用螺丝的螺纹来提供凹槽，然后你拧紧它并把背部从它里面拿出来
but this guy wasn't a straw maker by trade, how did he create this new object? So he starts out with this simple existing paper straw. And then he slots in a middle screw into the neck, and then he wraps dental floss around the screw So that when he tightens it down it creates ridges Right, and these ridges allow the thing to bend you know like an accordion So you just use the screws threading to provide the groove and then you tighten it and take the back out of it
然后你就得到了一根柔性吸管，所以真的任何人都可以做到这一点，对吧？他在专利申请中也说得很清楚。他说，看。我没有发明手风琴。我没有发明吸管。我所做的只是把这种灵活性与这种（你知道）用于喝水的直管结合起来，所以他把这个东西拼凑了出来，它立即彻底改变了这个行业吗？它做了什么？实际上这些柔性吸管花了一段时间才流行起来，这有点令人震惊。嗯，因为他兄弟拥有他的苏打水店。就像，当他得到他的，就像，他有一条通往市场的道路。对。
And then you get a flexi straw, so like really anybody could have done this right and he's really clear about this too in the patent application He's like look. I didn't invent the accordion. I didn't invent the straw All I did was I combined this idea of flexibility with this you know straight tube for drinking out of so he MacGuyvers this thing into existence does it revolutionize the industry right away? What does it do it actually took a while for these flexible straws to catch on, which is kind of shocking. Well, because his brother owned his soda shop. Like, when he's getting his like, he's got a path to market. Right.
然而不知何故，他花了大约10年时间才开始销售这些东西。那是很长一段时间靠希望生活。是的，确实如此。他最终在旁边做了其他工作。他做了一些房地产经纪人的工作，算是维持生计。他还从投资该业务的兄弟那里获得了现金注入，从他的妹妹贝蒂那里获得了一些商业帮助，据许多人说，她是运营的大脑。
And yet somehow it takes him like 10 years to start selling these things. That's a long time to live on hope. Yeah, it really is. And he ended up taking other jobs on the side. He did some work as a real estate agent, sort of keep it alive. And he also got cash infusions from his brothers who invested in the business, got some business help from his sister Betty, who, by many accounts, the sort of the brains of the operation.
然后终于，10年后，他们有了第一批买家，这与孩子或商店里的东西无关。那么谁是第一批购买柔性吸管的人？结果是这些大型医院，如果你仔细想想，这完全说得通。他们有受伤的病人、残疾的病人、躺在床上难以坐起来的人。
And then finally, 10 years later, they get their first buyers, and it has nothing to do with kids or stuff to shop. So who are the first people to buy Flexi Strossin? And it ends up being these large hospitals, which if you think about it, makes perfect sense. They've got injured patients, disabled patients, people lying in beds who have trouble sitting up.
所以这些柔性吸管，它们是（你知道）可弯曲的、一次性的、卫生的，它们非常适合这些医院环境。从那里，当然，它们进入了餐馆和儿童果汁盒等等，但它们是从医院开始的。这是一个非常有趣的通用设计例子，它确实被一个需要它的社区所采用，
And so these flex straws, which are, you know, bendable, disposable, sanitary, they're just perfect for these hospital environments. And from there, of course, they go on to restaurants and kids juice boxes and all that, but they start out in hospitals. It's a really interesting example of universal design, where it's really taken by a community that needs it,
然后每个人都意识到，嘿，这些对我们来说也挺好的。你知道，正如我们之前提到的，有一些运动要禁止所有塑料吸管。它们在社会中还有一席之地吗？我的意思是，这确实值得商榷，而且仍在争论中。有些人说，嘿，看，让我们回到这些纸质弯曲吸管。
and then everyone realizes, hey, these are kind of nice for us, too. You know, as we mentioned before, there's some movement to have all plastic straws banned. Do they still have a place in society? I mean, that's really debatable, and it's still being debated. And some people are saying, hey, look, let's go back to these paper bendy straws.
那行得通，对吧？那正是弗里德曼最初发明的东西。但随后许多残疾人权利活动家说，嘿，你知道，这对某些人来说很好，但它们也可能散架。它们没那么耐用。而且还有一个论点是，好吧，那么我们应该使用可重复使用的，对吧？它们更环保，比如玻璃或金属，但那些很难保持清洁。
That worked, right? That's what Friedman was inventing within the first place. But then a lot of disability rights activists are saying, hey, you know, that's great for some people, but they can also fall apart. They're not that durable. And there's also an argument that, okay, well, then we should use reusable ones, right? That are sort of more eco-friendly, like, glass or metal, but those are hard to keep clean.
它们可能会破裂。所以所有这些不同类型都有问题。对于真正需要它们的特定人群来说，保留塑料弯曲吸管有很强的理由。你可以看到弗里德曼最初的柔性吸管的图片和专利，以及它们的旧复古印刷广告。它们很令人愉快。
They can break. So there are issues with all these different types. And for a certain demographic of people who really needs them, there's a strong argument for keeping around plastic bindi straws. You can see pictures and patterns of Freemont's original flex straw and old vintage print ads for them too. They're delightful.
这在我们的网站上。网址是99pi.org。《99%隐形》本周由高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔制作，基于亚历克西斯·马德里加尔为《大西洋月刊》撰写的故事《一次性美国》。混音和技术制作由Sheree F Usif负责，音乐由Sean Rial创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是薇薇安·李，
That's on our website. It's at 99pi.org. 99% of visible was produced this week by senior editor Delaney Hall, based on the story disposable America by Alexis Madrigal, written for the Atlantic. Mix and Tech Production by Sheree F Usif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Vivian Lee,
艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、乔·罗森伯格和米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm找到他们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我Roman Mars，或者@节目99PI Org。
Avery Truffman, Joe Rosenberg, and Mitt Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in St. Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in downtown Oakland California 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org.
我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但你可以在nyanipi.org上收听和阅读更多使用日常物品来讲述整个世界故事的故事。Radio Tepi-R-X 本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you can listen to and read a ton more stories that use everyday objects to tell the story of the whole world at nyanipi.org. Radio Tepi-R-X There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但你可以在nyanipi.org上收听和阅读更多利用日常物品讲述全球故事的内容。Radio Tepi-R-X 本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。